[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch rudi zehe für den sport hallo
schön geplant und das sind unsere themen
heute
union in der krise die fraktionsspitzen
diskutieren konsequenzen aus dem
wahldebakel
mut machen im aartal bundespräsident
steinmeier informiert sich über den
stand des wiederaufbaus und
sieg in istanbul walter roboters gewinnt
max verstappen holt sich die wm führung
zurück
zwei wochen nach der bundestagswahl
steht die cdu vor einem scherbenhaufen
die rufe nach verjüngung erneuerung und
mehr mitgliederbeteiligung werden immer
lauter wolfgang schäuble sprach sich
heute dagegen aus die basis über einen
neuen chef abstimmen zu lassen andere
fordern den rücktritt des gesamten
präsidiums dem auch schäuble angehört
andrea maurer
die union ringt weiter mit sich selbst
auch das höchste parteigremium sieht
sich nun mit rücktrittsforderungen
konfrontiert das präsidium habe den
kanzlerkandidaten laschet gegen die
umfragewerte gegen die csu gegen die
fraktion und gegen die basis
durchgesetzt sagt der abgeordnete von
städten im zeitungsinterview aber dann
muss der kandidat auch die wahlen
gewinnen und eine regierung bilden
können sonst hat nicht nur der
kanzlerkandidat sondern das gesamte
parteipräsidium ein akzeptanzproblem und
muss seine ämter zur verfügung stellen
auch für philipp am tor haben die
letzten entscheidungen ohne basis
beteiligung ein akzeptanzproblem
deswegen ist für mich der entscheidende
punkt dass wir beim erneuerungsprozess
jetzt nicht nur aus funktionärs brillen
schauen sondern darauf schauen dass
400.000 mitglieder der cdu deutschlands
für uns der ausgangspunkt und der
bezugspunkte personellen erneuerung sein
müssen es ist die suche nach kompass
kapitän vielleicht auch einen neuen stil
zwischen csu und cdu friedrich merz
spricht von einem tiefpunkt unserer
zusammenarbeit und unseres umgangs
miteinander
stillos respektlos und streckenweise
rüpelhaft das dürfte auch als kritik an
ihm zu verstehen sein csu-chef söder der
präsentiert sich jetzt als versöhner
obwohl er selbst immer wieder gegen
laschet schießt unruhe stiftet die cdu
findet sich in einem sehr internen
diskussionsprozess
und ich glaube das muss man jetzt viel
verständnis dafür haben dass da sehr
viel unsicherheiten sind und das ist
auch unterschiedliche bewerbung gibt
morgen nun will armin laschet den
gremien vorschläge für den personellen
neuanfang machen auch ein
sonderparteitag ist im gespräch
die bundeskanzlerin ist währenddessen im
ausland unterwegs in israel wird sie
gerade als echte freundin gefeiert als
moralischer kompass für ganz europa
merkel ihrerseits bezeichnet ist als
geschenk und glücksfall der geschichte
dass es gelungen sei nach der shoa
solche beziehungen zwischen israel und
deutschland aufzubauen aus israel
michael warum
angela merkel in der holocaust
gedenkstätte jad vaschem
es ist nicht irgendein abschiedsbesuch
in irgendeinem land das aus der
verantwortung für die shoah eine tiefe
freundschaft wurde dankte man hier vor
allem merkel mit ihrem bekenntnis zur
sicherheit israels schuf sie vertrauen
zu einem anderen deutschland so auch
heute deutschland ist nicht neutral wenn
es um die fragen der sicherheit israels
geht sondern die sicherheit israels ist
teil unserer staatsräson
inzwischen sind wirtschaft wissenschaft
und kultur beider länder eng verflochten
und als gute freundin kritisiert merkel
auch zum beispiel israels verhältnis zu
den palästinensern da erscheint mir eine
zwei-staaten-lösung aus meiner
perspektive immer noch eine die richtig
ist wir haben über die alle aspekte der
siedlungspolitik noch nicht gesprochen
das ist dann auch vielleicht auch noch
dem abend vorbehalten denn durch die
siedlungspolitik ist natürlich die frage
der realisierbarkeit einer solchen
lösung schwieriger geworden bennetts
absage an die zweistaatenlösung macht
die gegensätze deutlich
wir haben die erfahrung gemacht dass mit
einem palästinensischen staat ein
terrorstaat entstehen würde
dennoch genießt merkel ein hohes ansehen
wie noch kein kanzler vor ihr so beliebt
angela merkel in israel ist so besorgt
sind die israelis welchen stellenwert
die neue regierung in berlin den
beziehungen einräumen wird in der neuen
generation von politikern so die sorge
können die lehren aus der vergangenheit
in vergessenheit geraten
österreich braucht nach dem rücktritt
von bundeskanzler kurz einen nachfolger
außenminister schallenberg soll morgen
übernehmen er gilt als vertrauter von
kurz auf dem weg zur bundespräsident van
der bellen sprach schallenberg von einer
enorm herausfordernden aufgabe kurz war
wegen korruptionsvorwürfen gestern
zurückgetreten bleibt aber vp-chef und
wird künftig auch die fraktion im
parlament führen
in polen demonstrieren zur stunde
landesweit tausende menschen ihr protest
richtet sich aktuell gegen ein urteil
des verfassungsgerichts danach verstoßen
bestimmte teile des eu rechts gegen die
polnische verfassung zudem fordern viele
der demonstrierenden eine eu
freundlichere und weniger
nationalistische politik der
konservativen pius regierung
zu corona schnelltests sind ab morgen
nicht mehr gratis wer sich testen lassen
will muss mindestens zwölf euro zahlen
ausnahmen gelten zb für kinder und
schwangere
die zahlen sehen aktuell so aus das
robert koch institut meldet 7600 zwölf
neue infektionen innerhalb eines tages
das sind
1448 mehr als vergangene woche die
sieben tage incidents steigt auf 66 1
wie läuft der wiederaufbau wie geht es
den menschen nach der jahrhundert-flut
im westen deutschlands bundespräsident
steinmeier ist heute ins ahrtal gereist
die verheerenden fluten mitte juli in
nordrhein-westfalen und rheinland-pfalz
haben
183 menschen in den tod gerissen die
meisten opfer mehr als 130 gab es im
urteil orte wie bad neuenahr ahrweiler
gezeichnet von der katastrophe hier
startete der besuch des
bundespräsidenten julia schröter
die bitte der betroffenen sie nicht zu
vergessen ist den bundespräsidenten wohl
im ohr geblieben begleitet von vize
ministerpräsidentin spiegel ist er
wieder ins tal gekommen vor allem um die
sorgen und nöte der menschen zu hören
die kameras sind
weiter von der aber
das unglück ist immer noch da die trauer
über die toten
der verlust von haus hab und gut und
deshalb
es ist so wichtig dass wir immer wieder
erinnern mut machen die straßen sind
aufgeräumt doch die massiven schäden
noch überall sichtbar viele häuser vor
allem tiefer im aatal sind nicht
bewohnbar strom und wasser sind da aber
kein gas
wir haben halt solange wir kein gas
haben auch kein fließendes warmes wasser
ich muss also in den dusch container
gehen oder zu meinem sohn mit dem auto
zehn kilometer weit weg fahren oder mich
zu hause mit dem wasserkocher und
gießkanne behelfen es ist schon ganz
viel passiert aber es ist erst ein
vierteljahr und ich denke um die aa
wieder zu dem werden zu lassen was sie
einmal war werden mindestens fünf jahre
ins land gehen große hilfe leisten nach
wie vor viele freiwillige unter der
woche packen täglich 400 bis 500 mit an
am wochenende mehr die solidarität der
freiwilligen tat und tut den menschen im
aartal gut auch weiterhin
vor seinem besuch im aartal überreichte
bundespräsident steinmeier in darmstadt
den deutschen umweltpreis und zwar an
die datenschützerin katrin böhning käse
und den [ __ ] forscher hans joosten beide
so steinmeier hätten das bewusstsein
dafür geweckt was nötig sei um die
biologische vielfalt zu erhalten und die
erderwärmung zu stoppen lasse moore
beispielsweise sind wichtig um co2 zu
speichern
und jetzt die formel 1 so was halt auch
nass und rutschig vor allen dingen
stetiger nieselregen hat heute in
istanbul für spannung gesorgt am besten
kamen valtteri bottas in seinem mercedes
mit den bedingungen zurecht er setzte
sich vor den red bull piloten max
verstarb und sergio perez durch lewis
hamilton wurde fünfter er wollte seine
laune nach dem rennen offensichtlich
nicht gern preisgeben lewis hamilton hat
sich in einem regnerischen rennen von
platz elf auf fünf vorgekämpft
vielleicht wäre auch mehr drin gewesen
denn sieben runden vor schluss holt sein
mercedes-team ihn an die box zum
reifenwechsel und zum unmut von hamilton
der gern mit dem reifensatz zu ende
gefahren wäre obwohl der seine beste
zeit schon hinter sich hatte durch den
stopp verliert hamilton dem platz auf
dem podium und schließlich auch die wm
führung an seinen ärgsten verfolger max
verstappen
tennisprofi angelique kerber hat ihr
auftaktmatch beim wta turnier in indian
wells gewonnen in drei sätzen besiegte
die deutsche nummer eins die tschechin
katerina senior war damit steht kerber
in der dritten runde und trifft dort auf
die russinnen kazak
fünf spiele fünf siege so die
beeindruckende erfolgsbilanz von
bundestrainer hansi flick morgen gegen
nord mazedonien kann die vorzeitige wm
qualifikation geschafft werden fittes
personal vorausgesetzt bei einem
abschlusstraining fehlte nur antonio
rüdiger der wegen rückenschmerzen
pausieren musste manuel neuer dagegen
ist einsatzbereit konnte nach
leistenproblemen wieder mitmachen in
nord mazedonien soll vorzeitig das
wm-ticket gebucht werden wohl eine
mannschaft auf dem platz haben die
miteinander fußballspiel die von enormer
aktivität geprägt ist und wir wollen das
spiel morgen gewinnen wir haben gesagt
wir wollen so schnell als möglich uns
qualifizieren für diese
weltmeisterschaft und da gehört dieses
spiel morgen auch dazu
nach einer intensiven trainingswoche und
sieben tagen in hamburg sind sie am
nachmittag abgereist ziel nord
mazedonien und drei punkte
ja dass du hast von sport dankeschön
routine fehlt noch das wetter morgen
kann es zeitweise regnen südlich des
mains bleibt es aber erst mal trocken an
den alpen hält sich länger nebel die
temperatur erreicht 10 bis 16 grad
danke für ihr interesse morgen begrüßt
sie hier um diese uhrzeit zum ersten mal
mitri sirin wir wünschen ihm und ihnen
einen guten start in die neue woche sein